we're living in a time and place when we
have drug aied almost every aspect of
Our
[Music]
Lives my name is Simon Wesley I'm the
dean of The Institute of Psychiatry
psychology neurosciences here at Kings
College London and um I'm delighted
today that um I'm talking to uh
Professor Anna LM have I've got your
name your surname right actually Le
Lea yeah that's right that works okay
where's it from it's actually German ah
right I should know that okay same with
my surname then it's also German okay
now uh Anna is the uh chief of the
Stanford addictions uh Center at the
University of Stanford obviously in the
Dual diagnosis Clinic there um but
that's I suppose partly why you're here
but you're really here because you've
you published um to to the Envy of
everyone in Academia you published your
book uh dopamine finding balance in the
age of indulgent I've got my copy here
you are available in the paperback from
all good bookshops particularly the New
York Times where it's the bestseller
right so Anna o over in this country um
we have a newspaper called the sun which
is regarded I don't know if you know it
but it's regarded as very very tabloid
very very popular um and and a lot of
people like us look down their noses at
it it has to be said but um what it what
it did uh a couple of years ago uh
writing about a subject to your heart it
said the headline was this it said um
cupcakes could be as addictive as
cocaine and uh the reason for this was
they cause a surge of the reward
chemical dopamine to hit the
decisionmaking area of the brain so Anna
talk us through that because I think as
the saying goes It's a little bit more
complicated than that isn't
it yeah I mean I think what the Sun
article and I'm not familiar with that
publication but I think what it's
getting at the you know is a core of
something that is true which is that our
food supply has become drug aied and
when I say drug aied what I mean is that
it's been made more potent which is to
say it releases more dopamine in our
brain's reward pathway and dopamine is
our pleasure and reward neurotransmitter
it's been made more accessible one of
the biggest risk factors for the
development of addiction is simple
access if you live in a neighborhood
where drugs are readily available on the
street corner you're more likely to try
them and more likely to get addicted to
them and it's more Bountiful so we have
this incredible supply chain where we
can get cupcakes delivered to our
doorstep you know within half an hour
and those things potency access quantity
and also frankly novelty our ability to
take something that's been reinforcing
change it slightly by adding a chemical
Moyet or changing the flavor or
combining two flavors together um is
what makes something a potential drug
and we're living in a time and place
when we have drug aied almost every
aspect of our lives uh which also means
that we're vulnerable to um compulsive
overc consumption leading into Addiction
in a way that is unprecedented in human
history we can today binge on almost
anything and we're proving ourselves
very likely to do that what I I noticed
from you know looking at your extremely
good reviews on Amazon and elsewhere Etc
though is a number of people who who are
under the kind of impression that
dopamine is itself an addictive drug
it's it's a the pleasure the pleasure
chemical uh I think another newspaper
described it but I I I I wanted just to
explore a bit because that's not quite
the case is it it's it's not the same as
you know heroin to which Sometimes some
people compare it with it's a it's a
rather different you know well for one
thing without dopamine none of us would
be alive yes absolutely I sometimes
people say to me I'm addicted to
dopamine and I say to them no you can't
be addicted to dopamine yeah dopamine is
the chemical signal That's essential for
our reflexive tendency to approach
pleasure and avoid pain but it's much
more complex even just in pleasure so
for example there's a very famous
experiment in which rats were engineered
to have no dopamine receptors in the
dedicated reward pathway and what the
researchers discovered is if they put
food in that rat's mouth it would eat
the food and seem to get pleasure from
the food as much as you can measure that
in a rat but if they put the food even a
body length the way the rat would starve
to death and the interpretation of that
has been that dopamine is not just
essential for pleasure it's also
essential for motivation and the way
that it gets us motivated to do the work
to to go get our reward is its
modulations through time so we're always
releasing dopamine at Baseline tonic
levels in the brain it's kind of like
the heartbeat of the brain and it's the
fluctuations in dopamine firing either
above baseline or below basine which
influence how we feel whether or not
we're motivated to do that thing again
in general intoxicants release a lot of
dopamine or increased dopamine firing
all at once in the reward path way
followed by dopamine freefall not just a
baseline but actually below Baseline
That's The Hangover the come down the
Blue Monday which during which we are
extremely motivated to consume more of
that drug again just to bring those
levels back up to Baseline because one
of the overarching physiologic drivers
of all living organisms is to return to
homeostasis homeostasis in this case
characterized by those Baseline tonic
levels whatever our resting set point is
for experiencing Pleasure and Pain it's
important to to recognize that drug of
choice is a very important additional
layer to this so what may increase
dopamine firing in one person's brain
may not do so or not may not do so to
the same extent in another person's
brain so for example when we think about
people Doom scrolling and people who get
addicted to watching the news well you
think to yourself well what's the deal I
thought dopamine was our pleasure uh
neurotransmitter it's not that it's that
for for certain individuals unique
wiring aversive stimuli might actually
be reinforcing also dopamine is the
neurotransmitter of novelty even
separate from whether the stimulus is
pleasurable or painful dopamine is is a
neurotransmitter that tells us something
is happening that's really important and
key for your survival and you need to
pay attention to it okay so it's neither
good nor bad is it to to say you know
you can't kind of characterize in the
way that you make cocaine or heroin and
and the increases that you get with with
both um opioids and cocaine are you know
thousands I don't know thousands but
massively larger than what happens when
you are gambling or watching porn I'll
come on to that because it's the opening
of your book obviously U well not
obviously if you've read it it's obvious
um and uh eating junk food Etc so we're
talking about all the a magnitude
difference aren't we well um I'm not
sure because the truth is that what what
when we it's very difficult to measure
absolute levels of dopamine in the human
brain we are basing much of this on rat
studies where we put a pro I I use I use
we I'm using the Royal we here I am not
a neurosci I'm not in the lab doing
these experiments my wonderful
colleagues do these this amazing work so
just take it with you know take it with
a grain of
salt neuroscientists are putting a probe
into uh the reward pathway of a rat's
brain and measuring dopamine firing
levels above Baseline in response to
certain uh certain stimuli so for
example in a rat eating chocolate
increases dopamine firing about 50%
above Baseline uh nicotine is about 200%
uh amphetamine cocaine is about 1,000%
so you know you have these
gradations but rats are not humans right
um in fact it's very difficult to get a
rat addicted to alcohol unless you
specifically engineer a strain of rats
to get addicted to alcohol um and when
we're talking about absolute levels what
we know for sure is that things like
gambling pornography social media video
games we know that they increase
dopamine firing in the reward circuitry
of the brain so the same um chemicals or
intoxicants that we think of drugs and
alcohol you know these these process
addictions or digital media they
stimulate the same part of the brain
what we don't know is whether it's more
or less uh than these classic
intoxicants and I would hypothesize or
speculate that it 100% depends on the
individual so for some individuals
opioids which we think of as highly
addictive may not actually increase
dopamine levels very much in a given
human whereas pornography might just you
know send it out out of the roof okay
now that that begs the question I mean
awful I mean we know that lots and lots
of people gamble they you know have a
their weekly lottery ticket and whatever
it is nearly all males watch pornography
it turns out most females as well but
you know only of the people who become
who play games only about two to three%
will become something that looks like a
gambling addiction or a or a video games
addiction Etc why don't the other 95% of
people go the same way whereas opium
opioids would would are far far more
addictive than that aren't they okay so
a couple key points here the first is
when we're talking about the relative
addictive nature of substances or
behaviors we need to really be clear
that access matters so when you look at
for example the rates of addiction to
alcohol or nicotine or cannabis all over
the globe you see much higher rates of
addiction for those substances because
they're mostly legal or in many
countries they're legal so they're very
very accessible right whereas um drugs
like LSD in the United States are so far
not legal you know not not they're not
you're not supposed to be obtaining them
easily right now because we have a Trope
around uh LSD and psychedelics being
treatment for depression or allowing for
a spiritual awakening people are using
them a lot more and as there's increased
access we are seeing increased rates of
psychedelic addiction harms due to
psychedelic so this is really really
important to think about um you know
that we can't just look at the rates in
the population without also accounting
for the prevalence or availability of
the drug all right but in in defense of
the younger generation which obviously
I'm not part of um one thing that's been
very clear in both the US and the UK and
I imagine many other countries as well
is that despite the uh easy availability
which gets cheaper and cheaper every
year in fact things like alcohol and I
don't it's very hard to get drugs I'm
told yet the rates in young people in
the last decade and more have been
steadily going down so rather you know
and that's that's because I'm an
epidemiologist so I have no idea why but
I do know that they are going down yeah
and which kind of goes against this idea
that this is all the fault of society
there's just too much of everything and
people just indulge and got no
self-control anymore but so why
why yeah so let me I didn't get to
finish answering your question okay part
of it is the ecosystem um and I can tell
you the rates of alcohol addiction and
cannabis addiction um are going way up
in the United States so we're seeing we
are seeing that our epidemiologic
findings correlate with increased access
and I think in general it's it's pretty
well confirmed that the more access you
have to an addictive substance the more
you're going to see um harms including
the harm of addiction we can use online
Sports bet is another example here in
the United States that's been illegal
for you know until some years ago and in
the states where online Sports spending
is now legal there have been 300 to 500%
increases in calls to hotlines for
pathological gambling okay but that but
that argument aside let's look at let's
look at the general vulnerability so um
only about 10 to 15% of individuals who
consume alcohol will go on to develop an
alcohol
so the vast majority of people who drink
alcohol don't become addicted to alcohol
um so so there we have a lot of
different factors going on I think the
bioc psychosocial conceptualization of
mental illness is really key here which
is to say we have biological uh
contributors to vulnerability
psychological contributors and then
social or environmental contextual
contributors we know pretty well if you
look at family studies and adoption
studies that if you have a biological
parent or grandparent with an alcohol
addiction you were at increased risk to
develop an alcohol addiction yourself
compared to the general population even
if you are raised outside of that
alcohol consuming home it's not going to
be one gene it's a complex polygenic
phenomenon but clearly and in my
clinical work it's very clear that there
are some people who are born with what
used to be called the addictive
personality we don't use that
terminology anymore we now talk about
people who have vulnerability to the
disease of addiction these are people
who can get addicted to almost anything
or even if they have a particular drug
of choice they become almost instantly
enslaved by it because of the particular
nature of their brain circuitry um as
part of their biological contributors
now when we look at psychological
contributors there's lots of things we
know that poverty unemployment
multigenerational trauma abuse um
ongoing stressors all of that increases
the risk of addiction it turns out if
you have parents who either implicitly
or explicitly condone substance use as
recreational fund or a coping strategy
those kids are more more likely to get
addicted conversely if you have a parent
who's a helicopter parent who knows
where their kid is what's in their
backpack what's under their bed those
kids are less likely to get addicted and
on and on and on you know so you can
find on to that in a minute actually I I
just wonder though if you wanted just to
to say why just levels of drinking not
addiction but levels of drug and and and
alcohol consumption are going down in
youth I mean that that's unequivocal
whether or not you had any thoughts as
why that might be when your hypothesis
you know in of the age of indulgence and
they're not indulging as much as
certainly I did and I don't know about
you Anna but well okay so I mean this is
this is purely hypothetical but my sense
is that they've switched those
vulnerable youth have basically switched
those Tendencies to digital media and
now you've got and we're seeing this
Rising rates of really video game
addiction very surprisingly youthful
pornography addiction social media
addiction all of it YouTube more and
more kids coming in and a lot of times
people push back and well you can't
really be addicted to a behavior trust
me you can these are kids are coming
morbidly depressed non-functional in
some cases suicidal they're consuming
you know 14 16 20 hours a day of digital
media uh and when we do an intervention
right so so what we see is some some
degree of dose dependency which is one
of the ways that we look at causality
you know if you look at most of the
studies around digital media social
media and psychiatric harms what you see
is tons of correlation so the more the
more people consume digital media the
more likely they are to be depressed
anxious Insomniac Etc so okay but what's
the chicken in the egg were they
depressed so they went online more were
they went online more they were
depressed we see it when we see it to
try to tease that apart one of the
things we can do is look at well
obviously the temporal sequence but
that's harder because that's usually
retrospective but we look at the the
dose dose influence so is it that the
more they use the more depressed they
are and we do see some signs of that but
even more importantly from my
perspective when we do a clinical
intervention and we take digital media
away from these kids for a long enough
period of time to reset reward Pathways
they get better without our having to do
any other intervention no Psychotherapy
no special medication so these kids are
like emerging from this TR
uh which looks very like the way that
people emerge from you know acute
withdrawal from addictive substances
okay let me let me just explore that a
little bit more because now you're
moving on to the treatments that you
give the advice you give and management
and and obviously you are advocating you
know everything in moderation or balance
which seems very sensible and your sex
addicted um engineer was it I'm not
entirely sure um with his machine uh and
I won't spoil the fun for everyone else
by saying what that was
um you told him to destroy the machine
or your highly anxious cannabis smoking
uh young woman you try told her to try a
month without we all of which seems
excellent advice um but you you you
actually use the word reduce your dopam
or I think you did or in your book you
do and one quote I I noted you said the
smartphone is the modernday hypodermic
needle delivering digital da 24 digital
dopamine 24 hours a day I just wondered
how much of that is you using things in
a metaphorical way to do what is
obviously sensible to um you know to to
um you know to to reduce your drug
intake to uh get rid of the the pleasure
machine that your engineer developed Etc
but you're you're you're using a kind of
scientific metaphor in order to explain
this to a patient who may not
particularly like it if you'd use you
know standard behavior therapy or or um
CBT or something like that
but you you you put it into
neuroscientific terms which makes it
more
acceptable absolutely and it's
explicitly it's explicitly met push back
on that one no no not going to push back
it is explicitly metaphorical I use
through many chapters in the book The
metaphor of a pleasure pain balance like
a teeter totter or seesaw in a kid's
playground um to represent how we
process Pleasure and Pain the cown that
we get after intoxication how that come
down or that dopamine deficit state is
what drives reuse in order to restore a
level balance or homeostasis so this is
a way to distill complex Neuroscience to
you know the point that we understand
what's going on um into a kind of um
portable image of what is happening in
our brains or what is likely happening
in our brains that people can take with
them um as they you know enter the world
and make decisions so for example I and
I use the process of neuro adaptation or
the efforts of the brain to try to
restore homeostasis as represented by
these little neuro adaptation Gremlins
that hop on the pain side of the balance
and to give you an example of how that
lands for some people um I had a guy who
was trying to quit smoking and he said
every time I get a craving for a
cigarette I just imagine that those
little neuro adaptation Gremlins are
jumping up and down on the pain side of
my pal balance trying to get me to smoke
again so that that's I think that's you
know that kind of metaphorical
representation of complex neuroscience
can be very helpful for people I will
also say that what's exciting to me
about a lot of the Neuroscience that
we're seeing now is that it actually is
an echo of what philosophers and
theologists have been saying for
centuries but we now we have
Neuroscience to to show it and I can
tell you that if I say to you know my
patient you know Epicurious said X or
Jesus said y they're not that interest
Ed but if I say hey neurons
neurotransmitters dopamine serotonin all
of a sudden I've got their attention oh
that's a wonder that gives me a
wonderful way in just to try a little
game with you okay no just a quick it's
very simple but um so um when would you
I wonder if you can get the author here
which is probably a bit difficult but
maybe the time so this is from a book
that I'm very fond of and he's talk
talking to a he and he says the greatest
curse brought down on us by techn ology
is that it prevents us from escaping
from the present even for a brief time
no one has any time to think anymore you
wantan to have a guess when that was
your dwell he you're pretty close
actually um it's actually Stefan schag
but writing it exactly the same time um
you're you're quite a Huxley person
aren't you rather than right I I was
gonna gu Alder next yes yeah but
actually Stefan schik but he's he's
actually writing about the decline of of
the the end of the hburg Empire from his
Exile in Brazil in 1942 it was the last
thing he wrote he sent it to his
publisher and the committed suicide the
next day but again it blaming technology
blaming the medium for the message uh is
what I'm getting getting out here um how
much are we doing that you know um when
when new technologies come in we have a
tendency to to say they are responsible
the new and particularly people our
generation have that tendency to say
that thing that we don't do uh but
others do children do young people do is
a bad thing without really fully
understanding I mean you know going
going back to the idiot box which is how
you know my my father talked about
television contrasted with you know
entertaining ourselves to death I mean
obviously you know there are so many
amazing things about the technology this
conversation we're having now um which
is really fun for me would not be able
to happen without this incredible techn
together but I I do think that it's it's
it's very clear that we are at a point
where we need to talk about the dark
sides of the technology we're not
putting the genie back in the bottle
we're not getting rid of uh you know
this amazing digital technology the
internet Etc nor would we want to but
clearly clearly when we have
five-year-olds who are viewing
pornography on their iPads you know we
have a very serious problem that we
individually and collectively need to
sort out and I think if we're being
honest with ourselves we can all
identify Even in our own lives um a
substance or behavior that we consume
more of uh more frequently uh and in
ways that are harmful to self and others
than we would like um and I you know and
I'm very open about my particular
compulsive behaviors in the book but I I
I I do that in part because I feel like
it's low low risk in the sense that I
know that I'm not alone fair enough I
was going to ask you about the the book
The the plug-in drug television Children
of the family which is 50 years old now
but quite a bit of it is similar to what
you're writing but it was about TV but
you've already talked about your father
and and uh beaten that one so fair
enough so Le let's move on a little bit
then you are talking about and I quote
here an overs sanitized and over
pathologized children uh the notion that
children you take issue with the notion
that children are uniquely vulnerable
and you say that by by by protecting our
children from adversity we have made
them deadly afraid of it now I
absolutely couldn't agree with you more
on that it's not a common view that many
have but Riff on it a bit more and tell
me why you came to this sure well I mean
this is you know I've been practicing
Psychiatry now for 25 years and it's
been a very clear
progression um you know over that time
period And I I live here in the heart of
Silicon Valley we have very many
privileged and wealthy people um we are
seeing more and more people um and young
including young people who actually
construct their entire identity around
their psychiatric diagnosis so for
example I went to speak to a local high
school I met with sort of the leaders of
the school they were to go around and
introduce themselves and the first was
like I'm Sally I have OCD I'm Bob I have
depression so we we've really um you
know we now use this kind of
medicalization framework to understand
ourselves we identify the locus of the
problem as a disease process within our
brains um you know for for better and
For Worse um and parenting has been
absolutely consumed with the idea that
if we do anything uh to traumatize our
children even by gently pushing back uh
on things they may not want to do we
will cause them trauma which leaves a
kind of literal psychic scar which then
sets us them up for future pain in the
form of post-traumatic stress disorder
all of which has parents scrambling
around this notion they need to make
their children more comfortable they
need to make sure they get them to a
psychiatrist get them diagnosed get
their depression treated so we've
completely and
radically 180 degrees reoriented on the
experience of pain suffering struggling
uh distress unhappiness to the point
where we can now consider pain in any
form uh to be a dangerous and it is the
job of parents and of psychiatrists and
psychologists and teachers and Camp
counselors to make sure that kids are
not experiencing any distress and as a
result I believe we are doing a huge
disservice to these kids because we are
making them feel as brittle as glass
that they can't actually go anywhere
without potentially experiencing some
kind of triggered harm and instead you
know this again this is really not these
are not new ideas but these are ideas
that I think are especially imminent and
pressing for our time and they're
they're getting worse um you know
instead obviously what we should be
doing is inviting uh pain into our lives
uh intentionally seeking it out because
we live in this rarified world where
we're insulated from pain we should be
encouraging our kids to struggle we as
parents should not seek primarily to be
our children's friends but instead to to
be uh providing the guard rails and the
realistic feedback that they're going to
need to be successful in their adult
lives that's the other thing it's very
difficult to get realistic feedback now
so for example in Academia when we write
recommendation letters nobody's willing
to put anything bad or negative in a
recommendation you could literally get
sued if that person then discovers you
and thwarted their chance I can see
where you're going with that one Anna
and uh my father want to write someone
to reference said Dr so and so been with
us for seven years and has been in
excellent Health throughout and that was
all say now then can I thank you once
again for coming and wish you luck and
um and look forward to your next um your
next book Thank You Simon
[Music]
okay